اليوميه مع مراسلي صباح العربيه ما علينا
الدويهي موضوع انخفاض معدلات الانجاب في
لبنان شو هو السبب اهلا فيك يارينا معنا
ليش ليش الناس بلبنان بطلوا اولاد يعني
راويه وعادل صباح الخير انا لم اسمع
السؤال حدي في هوا كتير
بهاويات الطيبين
ليش صار في انخفاض بمعدلات الانجاب في
لبنان
نعم يعني لا شك راويه انه الازمه
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والاجتماعيه ومترت
مع بارتفاع بتكاليف الحياه اليوميه ادت
الى انخفاض بعدد الولادات وتراجع بنسبه
الانجاب يعني لانه فحوصات الحمل
ومراجعات الحمل وحتى تكاليف الاستشفاء حتى
اذا كانت ولاده عاديه او قيصريه اصبحت
خارج المواطن او يحسب لها الكثير من
الحسابات عدا عن تكاليف ما بعد الولاده
يعني اذا كان بدنا نحكي عن حفاضات وحليب
ومعينات طبيه وادويه وغيرها كل هذا جعل من
الانجاب من الزواج اولا ثم من الانجاب حلم
مؤجل عند البعض يعني كل ذلك يدفع بلبنان
الى مجتمع هرم اذا ما استمر الامر على هذه
الحال لانه يعني من من سنه 2019 الى 2022
تراجعت نسبه الزواج ب 18% تقريبا اما نسبه
الانجاب الى اكثر من 35% ولهذا اسباب
عديده يعني عند القاتنين في لبنان هناك
خوف من المجهول وما سيحمله من القادم من
الايام اما من جهه اخرى فهناك هجره كثيره
للشباب الذي عندهم بعمر الانجاب كل ذلك
ادى الى هذا التراجع طيب ارينا شو قصه
الفقمه الراهب شو الحكايه شو هذه المهدده
طبعا وانت على البحر اليوم مشروع سكني
فقمه الراهب المتوسطيه دخلت مرحله
الانقراض يعني لم يعد عددها في لبنان
يتخطى اصابع اليد الواحده انا الان في
عمشيه الى شمالي من بيروت واقف فوق احد
المغاور البحريه حيث تقطن فقمه الراهب
التي يعني رصدها الغواصون هنا وابناء
المنطقه خلال السنوات الماضيه الذي حصل في
الايام الاخيره هو يعني ما اثار خوفهم هو
اقدام الحصول على رخصه للبناء فوق تلك
المغاور الامر الذي يهدد هذه الفقمه
ويخيفها ما يدفعها الى الهجره فالبيئيون
والابناء المدينه هنا تمكنوا من ايقاف
الورشه التي ترونها خلفي والتي من شانها
ان تخيف يعني عمليه البناء من شانها ان
تخيف هذه الفقمه وقد تدفعها الى الهجره
والفقمه المتوسطيه او فقمه الراهب
المتوسطيه هي من انواع الثدييات الست اللي
مهدده عالميا حتى يعني هنا التجاوزات
الماده العمراني والمخالفات البناء وغيرها
وحتى الصيد الج كل قد يكون يخيف هذه
الحيوانات ولكن في المقابل نلاحظ عادل في
السنوات الاخيره وعي بيئي في لبنان على
اهميه الحفاظ على هذه الكائنات ولعل هذا
الوعي البيئي ايضا انعكس في عرض البحر
لانه بحسب المراقبون وبحسب الصيادون هناك
اسراب من الدلافين واسراك القرش عادت الى
عرض البحر وانما ذلك يدل على عوده الحياه
البحريه وسلامتها ونظافه المياه بالتالي
نحن خايفين والله على هالفقمه تاجر ايضا
يارينا نعم شكرا جزيلا ويعطيك العافيه
وعندك بحريه على هالبحر اللي وراك ولا لا
يا ريس هي الرئيس
شكرا يا رينا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات